q revenu dernièrement sur les violences
conjugales donc tu as été victime doit
aussi par le passé enfin tu peux nous
raconter ce qui sait ce qui s'est passé
steak ont déjà alors j'ai pas je ne
situe pas la chose dans le temps parce
que par rapport aux mecs j'ai pas envie
qu'on cite d'accord ok c'est fin c'est
pour plus un connard les gars c'est un
vrai connard ça c'est donc dans mon
livre j'en parle mais c'est pareil j'en
parle à l'âge de 20 ans dans la
chronologie et je dis que ça m'arrivera
plus tard donc voilà d'accord donc je
dirais pas voilà tu veux papon d'accord
on a compris fiez pas au monde a compris
tu veux pas savoir que n'ouvre pas qu'on
sache qui sait et a raison mais même si
j'ai bien envie de qualifier ce monde de
merde
et pourquoi vous ne faites pas du coup
même si tu es très intime et très
personnelle ça serait de la vengeance
lui c'est quoi tu vois là ghorfi ça sert
à rien je fais pas une une guerre
personnelle
moi je suis là ce soir je me disais mais
je suis pas la porte parole qu'est ce
que j'ai à faire là et puis en fait je
me dis non je vais venir parce que j'ai
pas envie de fermer ma gueule parce que
ça arrive à plein de gens parce que j'ai
plein de copines autour de moi comme tu
utilisais camille aussi qui sont
victimes de sa qui sont souvent aussi
des d'ailleurs des personnalités un peu
atypique qui sont sont brillantes est
qui et qui se font quand même bouffer
par ces mecs là qui ont qui ont trop de
gentillesse qui entrent au de d'empathie
qui disent que ce qu'ils ont dépassé ce
que tu peux nous raconter son histoire
en fait c'est le jour où je décide de
quitter ce fameux connard à m'appeler
monsieur connard l'on appelait colère
mais en plus il est il est appelé comme
ça plutôt on l'appelle comme ça ça
d'accord mais que là qu'on tue dix
connards dans la rue se retourne et
celle qui se fait appeler comme ça
d'accord et donc je décide de le quitter
il est minuit je dormais et puis et puis
en fait ça s'est mal passé suite à quoi
tu décides s'était formé quand même au
dessus il n'y avait rien n'y avait rien
eu avant aucune violence avant si une
fois une violence jeunes avaient attrapé
par les cheveux
il m'avait plaqué sur le climat est
foutue des claques d'accord il apte à
laisser passer a déjà dépassé en disant
parce que moi je me dis toujours bon il
va comprendre c'est impossible enfin
pourquoi est ce qui est à dire prêt pour
pour et devient un enjeu il devient
voilà qu'est ce que je suis désolé je
voulais vraiment pas de faire mal je
suis acheté pas fait mal et toupie mois
s'est cassé rester je me dis bon donc tu
sonnes tandis que les passé sa jeunesse
est passé en me disant je lui donne une
autre chance
donc là il est minuit comme à 00h tu dis
si bien dans ma minutu décide de le
quitter comme ça et donc bon à la
deuxième fois ouais je
non je ne décide pas comme ça c'est que
le mec il était c'était un pm c'est un
pervers narcissique le mec c'était un
mec qui me manipulait qui était millan
qui était moi je suis tombé dans le
schéma de ce genre de personnage
plusieurs fois d'accord parce que j'ai
une personnalité qui est un petit peu
atypique et on pourra développer ça dans
un autre si tu veux mais je laisse un
petit peu passé ça et je me dis que ce
serait trop injuste que que le mec ne
comprennent pas à quoi donc jeu j'essaye
de de lui dire les choses il comprend
pas et ça se passe en fait le mec il
n'arrive pas à s'exprimer ou je ne sais
pas et est il que c'est tombé je m'étais
fait opérer des deux pieds j'avais deux
pieds je pouvais je ne pouvais pas
marcher j'étais vraiment en même temps
les deux pieds et du coup il m'a poussé
il m'a mis par terre il m'a bastonné par
dessus mais c'était terrifiant quoi
terrifiant tu étais tu peux l'avouer
mais vraiment vraiment vraiment un
moment je sentais plus tu sais à force
des coups dans la gueule tu sens plus
dire que tu deviens elle shop incroyable
ouais incroyable et donc qu'est-ce qui
après qu'est ce qui se passe après tout
un étage et c'est dans quel état bah
après je suis comme dans les pommes je
sais pas si j'ai perdu conscience
il est c'est à dire je te laisse ce nom
et menez comme ça après j'essaie de me
relever mais je peux pas donc je remplis
et je la trappe le téléphone pour
appeler les flics ils étaient toujours
là il était toujours il était en train
de partir et il me rattrape le téléphone
j'avais filmé il ouvre le poil vu un
poêle à bois chez moi il le fou dans le
dans le poêle à bois le téléphone ils
cassent la poignée du poêle à bois quand
même le mec une force il était déchaîné
quoi et puis j'avais un chat et le chat
il regardait comme ça puis miaulait et
je me disais [ __ ] mais c'est quelque
chose du chat c'est qu'il y avait autre
fils soit la tête a dit olivier talent
vous aviez votre fils dans la et dormait
au dessus un feeling on y lit dans un
autobus de pain non il était minuit
dormait c'était dans son premier mari la
pente
heureusement la limitation non mais
c'est vrai qu'ils aient donc après
qu'est-ce qui se passe après vous nous
avons voulu renvoyer ou bien c'était
terminé c'est là dans la peau qui l'avez
vu vous avez porté plainte derrière
ouais j'ai porté plainte il a été jugé
ça a pris du temps il a été jugé il a et
il a eu deux mille euros de d'amande et
puis évidemment tout le monde à elles
trois ans avec sursis
j'avais eu des nouvelles depuis enfin
après ouais ouais ouais ouais ce qui
vous met crime et moi je réponds jamais
quoi il m'écrit mais j'écris il ya deux
mois maintenant je souhaite à partager
cette bonne nouvelle avec toi j'ai
répondu que j'en ai à [ __ ]
non je réponds même pas bah oui en fou
peut-être bloqué numéro peut-être moi je
vais bloquer non mais ccc en plus c'est
ce qui se connaît ma voisine enfin bon
mec c'est un vrai connard vrai de vrai
[ __ ] comment tu t'en es sorti commente
a été traumatisée par cette forcément
pas en fait je sois dans la résilience
je pense que je dépasse les trucs que je
me dis ouais je pense que j'apprends de
tout tu vois c'est une épreuve et je me
dis ok je je vivrai plus à quoi
en fait c'est parce que j'ai besoin
d'aller vraiment fond du truc pour pour
moore tous ces bienfaits réussi à trop
construire derrière avec les hommes qui
étaient avec nous avec la print et
l'expérience web très vite ou non pas
très vite je passais très longtemps je
vais pas du coup je vais pas dire
combien mes dupeux a fait pas mal de
temps à apa ouais être seul
ouais tu arrivais pas ouais tu pouvais
plus faire confiance aux hommes ouais
mais j'ai géré la confiance ça revient à
mais aujourd'hui pas je vais super bien
oui